foreign
on this Tuesday night a developmentally
delayed woman sent to jail I really
didn't think she would be charged for
just being herself the system that
failed her and the fight to get her the
help she needs a global news exclusive
snow catastrophe on the west coast
that's why I got off this fight it's
been it's been far too long air travel
paralyzed with passengers stranded on
planes for hours I just think of
something completely unacceptable the
so-called Secretary of evil convicted
for her part in the Nazi Holocaust and
Argentina's heroic homecoming
the Ecstasy and the agony
as Millions flood the nation's capital
to celebrate their World Cup win
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Chris gayles
good evening and thanks for joining us
we'll get to those stories in a moment
but we begin with breaking news in
Toronto where eight teenage girls are
now charged with the murder of a 59 year
old man the young suspects none older
than 16 years allegedly attacked the man
in downtown Toronto just after midnight
Sunday Brittany Rosen joins us now with
more details on the crime Brittany
we're here at York and University Avenue
in downtown Toronto the site of where a
violent fatal stabbing took place over
the weekend according to Toronto police
a 59-year-old man was swarmed and then
stabbed to death the suspects being as
young as 13 years old now this happened
just after midnight as for the girls
they were arrested nearby and I just
want to reiterate their ages three of
them being 13 years old three of them
being 14 years old and two of them being
16 years old according to investigators
they all met through social media and
are believed to have been residing and
attending school in all different parts
of the city only a few of them had been
in contact with police prior to this but
at this point investigators are not
describing them as a gang however all
eight have been charged with
second-degree murder we don't know how
or why they met on that evening and why
the destination was downtown Toronto we
don't know we don't know how long
they've been acquainted together with
each other but I wouldn't describe them
as a gang at this point now at this
point police are not releasing the name
or identity of the 59 year old victim
they are still in the steps of notifying
next of kin but they describe this
individual as falling on Hard Times
someone who has recently introduced into
the shelter system and just again fell
on hard times he has a supportive family
in this area but police do believe that
there could have been other altercations
on the 17th and the 18th over this
weekend and so they're asking any
Witnesses or anyone who may have
additional information about these
altercations that took place by this
group of eight teenage girls girls
Brittany Rosen Global News
police have now named the victims of the
weekend's mass shooting in Vaughn north
of Toronto the gunman in his 70s killed
five people and injured another choosing
his victims after a years-long dispute
with the condo board Mike drolet has new
details about the events leading up to
the shooting
after two days of chaos a calmness has
fallen over this Vaughn Ontario Condo
building yet not enough time has passed
to offer Clarity For The Grieving
they're all wonderful people and
is a tight Community this is this is so
sad so sad and it's going to take all of
us a long time to get over this on
Sunday night a 73 year old condo
resident Francesco vili took his handgun
and knocked on the doors of three other
units he shot and killed five members of
the condo board including Rita camilleri
Naveed Dada Vittorio ponza Russell manik
and Helen manik a sixth victim Doreen
denino is in hospital in serious but
stable condition after being shot in the
face there was a knock at my door and
she opened the door and she was shot
everything happened so quickly
um
the shooting happened my primary focus
was my wife's well-being and our safety
Billy had been in a fight with the condo
board for years over electromagnetic
waves he believed to be emanating from
the electrical room under his unit it's
unclear what if anything was done but
Billy wasn't happy and began a campaign
of harassment in person and online very
soon
all you blind the people you can stay in
darkness for eternity
you may have the chance to reincarnate
it for purification
but that is entirely up to you in
November 2018 the condo corporation
started Court proceedings against Villi
which led to an order in 2019 for him to
stop harassing residents I will speak to
my last
and was found in contempt of court and
fined at thirty thousand dollars in
September 2021 but the harassment
continued and in Alaska desperate move
the board looked to have him evicted in
a hearing scheduled the day after he
went on his shooting rampage you know on
the surface it appeared it would appear
that there were some red flags but I
don't know that anybody could ever
predict this kind of an ending that
somebody would go to this extent it's a
tragic story that residents of this
building may never fully come to grips
with microwave Global News Vaughn
Ontario
a Saskatchewan family is horrified
they're intellectually disabled daughter
was sent to jail instead of receiving
the support programs she should be
entitled to the pandemic is partly to
blame and Heather York's West reports on
the heartbreaking circumstances facing
this family
curiosity about new arrivals is normal
at the Pine Grove Correctional Center
but when Jessica Stuckey arrived here in
November some inmates were immediately
concerned they were worried Stucky One
inmate told this prisoner Advocate was
distraught and did not seem to
understand why she was there she had
told me that her concerns were like you
know Sharia there's something really
wrong you know she's like she's like
childless she shouldn't be here Stuckey
is 24 and has a genetic chromosomal
abnormality called Smith magenus
syndrome it's left her with intellectual
disabilities she is kind of paused at a
developmental stage of about six years
old meaning that
normally she would she would hopefully
have a lot of community supports which
would help keep her out of trouble when
the pandemic hit in 2020 many of those
supports went virtual which was
particularly hard on people who needed
that human connection and Jessica really
needs human connection
so unfortunately
Jessica started reaching out to the RCMP
police say Stuckey began calling 9-1-1
multiple times a day threatening to hurt
herself and others police also said she
threatened to kill two support workers
but instead of getting help suited to
her needs Stuckey was arrested charged
with mischief and uttering threats
denied bail and placed into the penal
system I could feel people's frustration
in dealing with her but in a way given
her syndrome I really didn't think she
would be charged for just being herself
a medical assessment was court ordered
but because the nearest psychiatric
hospital was full Stucky ended up at
Pine Grove a correctional remand Center
where she remained for 36 days until
being found not criminally responsible
for her actions now she's in a
psychiatric hospital until a provincial
review board determines her fit for
release I'm horrified honestly that that
she would spend so much time in remand
there must be a better way
uh when we know that someone is
struggling with such
a disability the criminal justice system
is just not
the place to fix that problem Stuckey's
psychiatrist agrees in an email to
Global News Dr Ken Harrison said
Jessica's intellectual disability is not
something that can be treated in an
acute stabilization psychiatric hospital
setting as there is nothing with her
intellectual disability to stabilize
instead he's been recommending she
receive intensive community supports
through a regina-based Organization for
the past two years though every effort
to access enough provincial funding for
Jessica to enter the program have failed
Harrison said over the last two years
Jessica has made hundreds of calls to
Emergency Services mainly secondary to
loneliness on her part and not feeling
that her needs were being met
subsequently with some of the defining
characteristics of Smith's magenus
syndrome being impulsivity and a
tendency towards aggression this
culminated in the charges that were
eventually filed
in a statement a Saskatchewan Ministry
spokesperson tells Global News The
Province partners with third-party
service providers to intellectually
disabled adults in a way that best suits
their individual needs adding quote we
want Jessica Stuckey and her family to
know we understand their concerns and
are here as a support
but that support Jessica's mother says
has only LED Jessica to the criminal
justice system she's got so many
questions she doesn't really understand
what's happening I don't know whether to
encourage her or discourage her or I
don't know what to say or
it's why she's making her daughter's
experiences public hoping the next time
someone with intellectual disabilities
needs help they don't end up in
handcuffs instead
Heather urac's West Global News
winter officially arrives tomorrow but
Southern British Columbia has already
been hit hard by a snowstorm many
Canadian cities would struggle with 30
centimeters of snow overnight but for
the West Coast it's catastrophic one of
Canada's busiest airports Vancouver
International received 27 centimeters
forcing all arriving flights to be
suspended for about nine hours
passengers were left waiting some
stranded on planes that sat on the
tarmac for up to 12 hours Emily lassiton
reports on the airport chaos during the
busiest travel days of the year
planes stuck on the tarmac for more than
eight hours nowhere to go even those
arriving who made it to their Gates were
left in the dark and nearly out of food
there's people in here with diabetes
that don't have their meds don't have to
um so yeah it's just really bad honestly
we're getting pretty restless right now
just trying to you know get a sense of
direction try to figure out you know how
when are we gonna get off this plane the
heavy snow causing numerous delays and
cancellations a ground stop in effect
halting flights from arriving even with
plows out and shovels and head the
damage was already done we backed up
about 15 feet and then we stayed on the
tarmac for about seven and a half hours
and then they said that unfortunately
due to weather conditions we couldn't
make it
um out the frustration on the tarmac
also felt inside people trying to make
do finding a place to sleep and stay
warm YVR staff pitching in bringing
snacks to people waiting inside airport
officials just saying the crews are
working hard to get operations back to
normal and Luggage back to people we've
been waiting in the arrivals area to see
about our luggage do we get it do we not
get it no one has told us a thing five
days before Christmas it looks like some
will be spending the night here there's
some hope flights are making it out just
at a very slow pace I think we're going
on the same plane okay we're going to
rebook you guys at nine o'clock tonight
and check-in counter opens at four
o'clock Emily laziton Global News
Richmond BC
there was chaos and backlogs on the
roads to Vehicles slid out or got stuck
on Hills plows couldn't keep up and even
major highways in and around Vancouver
were covered in Slippery compacted snow
the Ministry of Transportation told
drivers to avoid all non-essential
travel in the Lower Mainland and Central
Vancouver Island and more than two dozen
ferries connecting the two regions were
canceled
The Fallout after some struggling
veterans were offered medical assistance
in dying coming up the departure at
Veterans Affairs Canada
some major new developments today in
historic Global News first broke back in
August a spokesperson for veterans of
Ferris Canada confirms the employee who
improperly discussed medical assistance
in dying with at least four veterans is
no longer employed at the department
Mercedes Stevenson joins us now with the
details Mercedes
Chris Global News has learned the
Veterans Affairs Canada employee who
inappropriately raised medical
assistance in dying with at least four
veterans is no longer working for the
Department a spokesperson for veterans
affairs minister Lawrence McCauley's
office told global news that the
departure came after a protracted Labor
Relations process was resolved this week
the government would not say if the
employee was fired or received Severance
the move comes after a firestorm of
outrage in the veterans community back
in August Global News broke the story
that the VAC employee in question called
a combat veteran out of the blue to tell
him that the traumatic brain injury
treatment he was looking at was very
expensive and the veteran said that the
employee then repeatedly suggested that
she could instead help him seek medical
assistance in dying as an alternative
raising it repeatedly even after he told
her to stop the veteran said the service
agent went on to tell him that she had
helped another veteran Act access
resources for medical assistance with
dying and that he had gone through with
the process and that that option was
better than him quote blowing his brains
out or driving his car into something
the interaction left the veteran
disgusted and concerned that other vets
may have had the same experience as him
something the department initially
denied but then later admitted to an
internal investigation confirmed that at
least four veterans were offered medical
assistance in dying dating back to 2019.
in November the cases were referred to
the RCMP for a potential criminal
investigation Chris
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
Mercedes
Canada is reportedly set to spend an
estimated 7 billion dollars on 16 F-35
fighter jets the Canadian press says the
Department of National Defense recently
received quiet approval to buy the
fighter jets along with the related gear
the liberal government hasn't confirmed
the report only saying that the 88
advanced fighter aircraft outlined in
Canada's defense policy will be acquired
she's the so-called Secretary of evil
just ahead why her trial could be the
last of its kind
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
visited front-line troops in the eastern
city of bakmut where some of the
fiercest fighting in recent weeks has
taken place his country is now marking
300 days since the Russian invasion
explosions rang out in the distance as
the president thanked residents and
soldiers for their strength and
motivation and held a moment's silence
for lives lost the conflict in Ukraine
has killed tens of thousands of people
driven Millions from their homes and
reduced cities to ruins
more than 75 years after the end of the
second world war a German Court
convicted a 97-year-old woman who worked
as a secretary at a Nazi concentration
camp she was found guilty of being an
accessory to the murder of more than ten
thousand people Redmond Shannon reports
arriving to face Justice after three
quarters of a century the 97 year old
was a typist in the Commander's office
sat stuttoff concentration camp in what
is now Eastern Poland the court decided
she knowingly and willingly supported
the cruel death of more than ten
thousand prisoners during the second
world war it handed her a suspended
sentence of two years in prison
the German State prosecutor said
fushner's job allowed her to know
exactly what was happening in the camp
when the trial began last year she fled
her care home before being apprehended
in a nearby City during proceedings a
historian gave judges a tour of stuttoff
showing them how forsner would have been
able to see the Camp's brutal conditions
from her office weeks into the trial she
told the court I'm sorry about
everything that happened I regret read
that I was inched off at the time that's
all I can say
it was only in 2011 that the German
legal precedent for complicity in the
Holocaust was set in the trial of death
camp guard John demyanyuk I think it's
it's time to recognize that as a as the
world Community we failed uh to really
prosecute the people who were part of
the Nazi killing machine most potential
suspects are now dead or very old
Canada's last known wartime Nazi helmet
Oberlander died last year before he
could be deported to Germany if there's
one hope that comes from this entire
thing is that people will learn about
the terrible things that were done to do
simply because of the fact that they
were Jews and that they will remember
where anti-Semitism can lead to
fortuner's conviction may be the last
such lesson the world learns at least
from the second world war Redmond
Shannon Global News London
[Music]
World Cup champions next incredible
scenes from Argentina's homecoming
parade
Buenos Aires Argentina turned into a
street party with massive crowds today
Millions celebrating the crowning
achievement of their national soccer
team and Superstar Lionel Messi Ross
Lord reports
after winning the top prize in the
world's most popular sport the
government declared this a bank holiday
in Argentina so everyone could celebrate
this fan says he's been crying tears of
joy for days
almost 40 years after Argentina last won
the World Cup its Sensational victory
over France on Sunday redefines
jubilation
this fan says the team United the
country to enjoy a wonderful moment an
opportunity to take their minds off Grim
realities like a staggering inflation
rate of 92 percent among the highest in
the world
[Applause]
by some estimates more than a million
people gathered to celebrate in the
streets of Buenos Aires the congestion
immobilizing the player's bus and
forcing them at one point to be moved to
a helicopter the main focus of the
throng's adoring eyes is Lionel Messi a
likable Superstar whose pursuit of the
World Cup in four previous attempts had
come up empty some argentinians resented
Messi for moving away and playing
professional soccer for a team in Spain
to soccer fans around the world Messi's
Triumph confirms his position as the
greatest player of all time this couple
traveled from India to Buenos Aires
anticipating Messi would come through
Messi is
[Music]
n't a group it's from our heart at age
35 Messi says his World Cup days are
over fitting it seems now that he's
brought the game's most coveted prize
home and put any remaining doubts to
rest
Ross Lord Global News
and that's global national for this
Tuesday I'm Chris gayles tonight's York
Canada is this festive front yard in
McGregor Manitoba just west of Portage
la Prairie we love to see your festive
Canada photos so please email them to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks for
watching
[Music]